ومن القاهره تنضم الينا كل من والده الطفل
بالتبني امال ابراهيم ميخائيل والكاتب
الدكتوره فاطمه نعود صباح الخير لكما يعني
السؤال الاول اللي والده الطفل بالتبني
طبعا ما هي الاجراءات التي ستتخذونها بعد
قرار المحكمه بعد الاختصاص بهذه القضيه
سيده امل السؤال لك
ايوه ايوه حضرتك
نعم ست امال السؤال ما هي الاجراءات التي
ستتخذونها بعد قرار المحكمه بعد الاختصاص
بهذه القضيه
[موسيقى]
القرار اولا واخيرا لربنا وانا طالبه يعني
طبعا دلوقتي المكانش ابن ابن هيجيني
بالمحكمه يبقى الست الريس هو اللي يجيبه
لي
سيده اعمال اول شي اقول لك كل عام وانت
بخير وان شاء الله عيد الام الجاي يكون
ابنك في حضنك يا ربي بس ردت اقول لك يعني
ما هي الخطوات الاخرى التي تاخذوها اليوم
وشو كيف صارت القصه بالضبط اذا فيك تعطيني
خلفيه اكثر
[موسيقى]
هي القصه
شنوده كان في كنيسه وفي حمام الكنيسه
وحضرتك يعني من خمس سنين فاتوا كان في
تفجير يعني كان في تفجير في الكنائس ازاي
واحده مسلمه هتخش الكنيسه وهو كان في
تفتيش او الوقت ده كان فيه تفتيش وكان
اللي يخش ببطاقه يعني ازاي يعني ما فيش
واحده مسلمه هتخش نعم طيب ما في يعني امه
مسيحيه نعم ايوه حضرتك طيب ما بعرف
الدكتوره فاطمه نعوت معنا ولا لا
نعم دكتوره فاطمه يعني صباح الخير لك اولا
وما الذي دفعك باستضافه
الطفل شنوده في او في طلب استضافه الطفل
شنوده في منزلك لحين البت بالقضيه
طبعا كل الشارع الثقافي في مصر
ومصر بلا استثناء الا القله يعني المتطرفه
تدعم هذه السيده الجميله وتدعم امومتها
الامومه هي الرعايه
والعطاء والسهر من اجل
رعايه الصغار وليست الانجاب والتخلي
وبالتالي فكلنا معها انا كنت معاها في
المحكمه يوم 18 مارس لما رفضت الدعوه لعدم
الاختصاص بعد تداول في القضاء لمده سنه
مثلا او اكثر الولد بقى له سنه وشهرين لم
يرى امه ولم ترى هي الا مره واحده ساعه
الطب الشرعي
ومحروم وهو لا يفهم شيء خمس سنين وكان
اربع سنين ساعتها لا يفهم ماذا يجري لهذا
انا كتبت قصيده على لسان شنوده عنوانها
ايها الكبار لن احتفل معكم بعيد الام لانه
لا يفهم ماذا يجري يعني ايه
يتحرم من حضن امه فانا فكرت لان احنا
هنبدا الدوره دوره القضاء من الاول هذا
الطعن ستعاد المحاكمه وربما تسترق سنوات
كثيره اخرى لهذا فكرت انه
استضيفه في بيتي حتى تستطيع ان تراه وامال
الى السيده امال لماذا سؤالي الان الى
السيده امل لماذا رفضت طلب استضافه شنوده
عند الكاتبه الدكتوره فاطمه
حضرتك انا ما رفضتش انا رفضت في اساس ايه
ما تاخدهوش على اساس مسلم تاخذه على اساس
شنوده فاروق انا مستعد انا مش مشكله عندي
بس على اساس يبقى
يوسف لا
نعم
سيدنا لحظه واحده
عندما فكرتي بتبني شنوده
تفضلي انا
مهتم
لانني يعني اهتم بالانسان اكثر لان
العقيده شان الخاص بين الانسان وبين ربه
وانت اقول كمان ان انا يعني ليس عندي
رفاهيه وقت ولا كذا انا عندي ابن متوحد
قراء يعلمون هذا وكتبت كتاب عن التوحد
فانا يعني مدخمه اليوم لا يكفيني لا اجد
وقتا للنوم اصلا ولكن افعل هذا يعني هذا
الاقتراح الذي سحبت وتراجعت عنه ما دامت
صديقتي الاستاذه امال السيده امال رافضه
فانا كان في الفكره كلها انها يستطيع ان
يرى امه وان تراه نعم السيده امال يعني
سؤال خلينا نحكي شوي قانونيا عندما فكرتي
بتبني جدوده لماذا لم تدرسي القوانين او
تلجئي لمحامي مختص بالتبني بتكون يمكن
الطريقه اسهل
حضرتك انا ما فكرتش في اي حاجه انا محرومه
بقالي سنين وصدقت ما لقيتش نودا صدقت وما
لقيته في الكنيسه وخدته وحده ضانته ده يوم
كان عنده يوم اربع سنين احتضنت وسبت علينا
لقيته في الكنيسه في حمام الكنيسه فالاب
الكاهن قال لي طالما انت ماسكه فيه
وما معكيش اطفال خديه ولما ريحته
من الشارع يعني عندها هويه او لا الطفل
عندها هويه باسمكم او لا
الطفل خدته لمده باسمنا باسمنا مستحيل
مستحيل ام مسلمه هتحطه في كنيسه ومستحيل
ام مسيحيه هتحطه في جامع احنا في مصر
معروف كده ان الطفل يعني طفل الذي يولد
على يعني بشكل انا اسفه يعني
سفاحا المسلمه بتحطه في جامع المسيحيه
بتحط كنيسه واضح جدا ان الطفل مسيحي ده
اذا تكلمت عن العقيده اذا مهتمين بالعقيده
هذا الطفل الذي لم يخطر شيئا طيب هو طبعا
المهم نهتم بالطفل اولا واخيرا طيب برايك
يعني ليش ما تتحول الى قضيه راي عام
هي قضيه راي عام بالفعل ولكن لا اعلم
لماذا يعني يتجاهلها الاعلام المصري الى
حد ما الى حد ما يعني يجب ان تكون قضيه
راي عام وبالفعل يوم ما رحنا المحكمه مع
مجلس الدوله مع يوم 18 مارس كان هناك كثير
جدا من الناس
المتضامنه مع اسمنهم مسلمين مسلمون
ومسيحيون
السيده امال والسيد فاروق وطبعا كنت انا
منهم
اليوم عيد الام شو بتتمني او شو بتطلبي
بعيد الام بالنسبه للطفل شنوده
بتمنى ابني يبقى في حضني عاوزه شنوده يبقى
في حضني وبطلب من سياده الرئيس
سياده الرئيس
سياده الريس عبد الفتاح السيسي
والست انتصار السيسي ارجوكم ارجوكم اتوسل
اليكم اعتبروا شنوده ده حفيدكم اعتبروه
حفيدكم
ترجعهولي وحضرتك يا استاذ يعني يا ست
الريس شوفتي شنوده مؤخرا ابوه للمصريين
كلها اعتبرني اعتبرني انت ابويا رجع لي
ابن شنوده انا مش عاوزه اي حاجه من الدنيا
انا عاوزه
اوقات الطب الشرعي وكل ما اجي احضن ابني
ياخدوه مني يا شنوده يقولوا لي
نعم خلال عامل وشهرين منذ يعني انتزع من
حضنها لم تره الى مره واحده منذ ثلاثه
اشهر او قرابه هذا لكن انا كل ثقه كل ثقه
انا الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي سوف يحسم
هذا الامر في القريب كل ثقه بهذا ان شاء
الله ايمان مطلق ان الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي لن يخذل هذه السيده شكرا جزيلا
لكما الا امل ابراهيم ميخائيل والكاتب
الدكتوره فاطمه نعود ويا رب يرجع لك ابنك
استامل